et on va faire un point sur la situation
sur le terrain avec notre correspondant
believer crade notre correspondant à
kiev dans la capitale ukrainienne
bonjour à vous de l'hiver je voudrais
faire un point avec vous sur les
informations qui nous parviennent au
compte gouttes 1 ce matin on a appris
que la russie en tout cas dit avoir
détruit les bases aériennes et
l'intégralité est de la défense anti
aérienne ukrainienne l'ukraine de son
côté affirment avoir abattu cinq avions
et un hélicoptère russe comment prendre
ces informations là vous sur le terrain
quelles sont les appelait les
informations qui vous parviennent
en réalité on a du mal à suivre parce
que il y a des informations sur des
attaques a tellement d'endroits
différents qu'on a du mal à vérifier
parfois il ya des vidéos qui sortent
mais il semble effectivement que les
aérodromes militaires de tout le pays
ont été ciblés même dans des villes à
l'ouest de l'ukraine comme ivano
frankivsk ou le vivent ou encore dans le
centre de l'ukraine ou man des endroits
qu'on ne pensait pas vraiment dans les
scénarios du pire qui pourraient être
ciblées hormis l'est et le d'une basse
il semble toutefois que ce n'est que
l'infrastructure militaire qui a été
ciblée et notamment effectivement ses
défenses aériennes même si il y à eut un
missile ce match qui a apparemment qui a
battu dans la ville d art kif je ne sais
pas exactement dans quel quartier mais
dont les photos que j'ai vu il y à une
église juste à côté donc il faut penser
que c'est une zone civile et non pas
forcément un cibles militaires
gulliver vous vous trouvez à kiev
comment réagi pour le moment la
population
je suis dans le centre ville de kiev à
l'heure où il est normalement il devrait
avoir des embouteillages dans la rue
derrière moi vous voyez qu'il n'y en a
pas j'ai regardé google maps pour
regarder qu'en est il des rues des
routes qui sortent de la ville et là
effectivement il ya des embouteillages
donc je pense qu'on peut tirer la
conclusion qu'une certaine partie tu es
la population par mais j'ai parlé à des
gens ici dans cette rue ce matin eux
n'ont pas dit qu'ils avaient l'intention
de partir il était vraiment dans le
désarroi ils m'ont dit qu'ils ne
savaient pas faire ça elle ne savait pas
quoi faire excuser moi deux personnes à
qui j'ai parlé étaient venues dans le
centre ville pour se rendre au travail
et on appris en découvrant que leur
travail était fermé c'est à ce moment là
qu'ils ont commencé à regarder
l'actualité et on appris ce qui se
passait donc elle était vraiment
absolument sous le choc
gulliver ces derniers jours le conflit
se situer aussi sur le code de la
communication de part et d'autre de la
russie à l'ukraine vous comment les
informations vous sont communiquées ce
matin est ce que c'est la panique est ce
que au contraire le président zelensky
se veut rassurant comment les ukrainiens
sont sont informés de ce début de guerre
qui a commencé en europe
je ne sais pas si france 24 a pu
diffuser un extrait du message vidéo
enregistré par le président ukrainien
volodimir zellers et matin j'espère que
si on l'a pas fait ouais alors où vous
avez vu il a dit que la loi martiale a
été déclaré il a dit que l'ukraine se
défendra et il a appelé au calme et il a
appelé aux citoyens de rester chez eux
je ne sais pas si cette instruction va
rester valables pendant le reste de la
journée parce que ces derniers jours il
avait aussi mis beaucoup d'emphase sur
la nécessité d'assurer que l'économie
continue à tourner et qu' il y ait de
quoi fournir les besoins financer
l'armée alors peut-être que tout à
l'heure maintenant que on a une vision
un petit peu plus clair de quelles sont
les cibles de ces attaques pour le
moment et de qu'est-ce qui se passe
exactement peut-être que plus de
l'endroit où les gens travaillent vont
ouvrir et les gens vont commencer à se
rendre au travail ça je ne sais pas pour
le moment clairement le président se
voulait rassurant mais personne ne peut
se leurrer l'heure est extrêmement grave
il y a des tonnes de tanks russes qui
ont traversé la frontière depuis la
crimée
selon les gardes frontières ukrainiens
il y a eu des attaques et des tentatives
et je pense qu'il y a eu des traversées
de frontières mais je ne peux pas le
confirmer à sion pour cent dans le nord
venant de la biélorussie donc des
véhicules militaires russes donc en plus
de ces de ses frappes il y à aussi sur
le terrain une invasion terrestre
qui a lieu non pas uniquement dans le
dôme basse
merci gulliver on vous retrouvera